hi Samuel leaves here and this video is
all about mortgages so if you've got
mortgage questions you will know whether
you can get a mortgage what type of
mortgage to get or you're confused over
mortgages then this videos for you so
stay tuned so I have here a sheet of
questions and andrew andrew by the way
is from regions core financial and he's
my mortgage advisor and also does a lot
of work for our students and i've got
here a list of questions that you
probably no doubt get asked all the time
and read right yeah so would it be okay
if I read them to you and you can answer
eloquently carry on excellent so the
first question that I get asked quite a
lot Andrew is if people say if I haven't
got a current mortgage but I have money
and good credit can I get a buy to let
mortgage there are occasions when you
can quite often you'll be told that
there's sets of rules about this there
aren't any formal rules but there's a
consensus that runs through mortgage
lending most of the time you do have to
own a property not necessarily to have a
mortgage but we've done one yesterday
for one of your clients where she
doesn't own any property at the moment
she's a tenant but she did own one two
years ago and we been able to establish
from the land registry her ownership of
that property two years ago and the
lender said that's fine
we'll do a buy to let mortgage she has
got experience of being a property owner
yeah if you've got no experience so you
28 years old you've got 50 thousand
pounds in the bank yep and you've lived
as a tenant right foot for all your life
is there no way that you could get a buy
to let mortgage yes we've just done two
a three of those now because there are
two or three lenders who will consider
it based on credit score and how much
your income and outgoings along yeah and
basically I think what they're doing is
they're working out that if the
buy-to-let thing didn't work can you
still afford to pay that mortgage based
on your income sure this literally when
I say two or three it is literally two
or three and you have to pass their
credit score which can be quite tough
and you have to have minimum earnings
and that type of thing it is the
interest going to be absolutely it still
no we the two we've done are very
competitive
so that ordinary high street rates so
they're not being penalized because
they're outside the normal ending
cartier salon okay what about it here's
another question what about if you've
got you've got a property yeah you've
got a residential mortgage but your
incomes really love and you want to get
a buy to let mortgage and really found a
really good property but you have not
really got an income we've got a very
low income can you get a mortgage in
that position the answer is yes there's
an increasing number of lenders who say
we have no minimum income requirements
that's great
so until three or four months ago there
were only three or four now there's four
or five so it seems to be a trend
because a lot of people a lot of my
students they take himself out the game
don't they just rate where they'll say
oh I've got a low income yes therefore
yes I can't get them all good yes but
that's not necessarily the case it's not
necessarily a snow right okay um what
about age what about if you're below
twenty-one how old do you have to be to
get a buy to let mortgage there are no
rules as I say but most lenders say
you've either got to be twenty five or
twenty one yeah if you're under 21 we
have done them for people under 21 but
often the lender requires that there is
somebody else on the mortgage who is
over 21 right so as long as one of the
two applicants qualifies then then
they're okay that's another thing
because we've been having some of our
students who like to read you for
instance yes who can't get a mortgage
she's been taught absolutely not she's
got no income she's below the minimum
age right it's just not happening
but then you've spoke to her and you've
said but if you could find someone else
how does that work some mortgage lenders
require that both the applicants or if
it's more than two up to four applicants
that they all qualify for that lenders
criteria yeah but some of them say no as
long as there is one person on the
mortgage who qualifies to meet their
criteria there can be other people on
there as well so if I was 18 year old 18
years old
yes had no credit bad credit or whatever
and just could not get a mortgage yes
but my mom was willing to help me out a
little bit how would that work would she
be cast as a guarantor or a mortgage
host and what does that look like the
mortgage host is a is not a term
generally used by mortgage lenders it
would just be a joint mortgage with mom
yeah and you weren't assisted you use
the word assisted something to call them
in by sister tendency or something oh
right well what you could do is you have
to work out between yourself a mum who
actually owned which bits of the
property so do you both owned the whole
property as a husband-and-wife normally
do or does mum own 50% of it in you own
50% or those those percentages tenants
in common at school that's in common it
doesn't have to be 50/50 it could be
nine to ten spoke to my mom yes and she
said Samuel you're 18 years old you
can't get a mortgage what we'll do is I
can you can put me down on the name as
well
yeah and I'll have just one percent
stake in the property yes and then in
two years time you can refinance
absolutely and then all I have the
mortgage in my name completely
absolutely too good to be true no it
does work the thing that we have to
remember is and that we have to remind
mummys that although that the
percentages of the ownership are perhaps
1% of 99 percent the liability for the
mortgage is a hundred percent for both
of you yeah so although she's on the
mortgage the lender isn't interested in
percentage of ownerships yeah the
lenders got two people to fall back back
on for the whole mortgage so if you
disappear to Australia and you've had
enough and leave mum in the lurch she's
still responsible for the whole mortgage
yeah oh if mum goes off somewhere and
leaves you you're all responsible what
you say to your mom or whoever the
person is is look this is a very good
problem to hit here is that if I
disappear then the house is yours and if
it's a good house yes assumably if mums
got some sense always mum cares and
wants to help yes then that should be
okay but it's really strange how the
lender the lender would say no you can't
get the mortgage but then mom can come
up for two years then go off and then
the lender has no control over mum
coming off the mortgage it's just that
that lender or another lender after two
years yeah we'll just assess it and
it'll be what's called a transfer of
equity and if they think well it now
stands on his on his own part then then
yeah love it next
thank you a mortgage yes what is a
height of a language and when do you
need one right
the the term HMO is slightly confusing
sometimes because an HMO proper is a
licensed premise
so it's a property that's been purchased
and somebody has converted it into a
property which is no longer a private
dwelling for a family to live in it's
it's a property to be rented out in
individual rooms with communal
facilities perhaps with fire doors smoke
alarms and that type of thing
but it is also a property that's been
registered by the local authority in the
area which are buying the property as an
HMO as a house for Multiple Occupation
so it's covered by that local authority
license however the word HMO is often
used for something which is more relaxed
which is a house of Multiple Occupation
where it's almost like an HMO but it's
just a house yeah we we buy i'm AlterNet
yes I'm ultimate so so the term HMO
strictly speaking stands for a property
that's licensed by the local authority
which has gone through the licensing
program otherwise aren't like that no
and then my own opinion is those are
attractive because if ever you come to
sell it you don't have the situation
where you have to sell it as an HMO yeah
it's a family dwelling so the properties
that I often bring to you what would you
call them not hate them out because
they're not registered they're not being
licensed on sweets they're just a house
that's being used as a multi let in the
main mostly I would describe that just
as a multi-layer or a small HMO that's
right so what type of mortgage does that
smaller multi that type of property
maybe it's just a normal house you
renting out to fall professional yes
what type of mortgage does that mean
some lenders treat multi let's and HMOs
is the same so they would regard it as
an HMO from their own point of view so
they're underwriting and the mortgage
deals that they offer would be HMO yes
but some of them there's a little quirk
in the system in that they'll say well
no there's two or three lenders will say
if it's a multi let we'll treat it as a
standard by too late so you'll get
standard terms but it is literally only
one or two yeah but a common way of
dealing with it is to say that even if
it's a multi let if all the tenants sign
the same assured shorthold tenancy
agreement then they don't the lender
won't regard it as an HMO or multi late
they say it's a standard tenancy yeah as
if it's just a family all signing the
same tenancy agreement
and that can get you a wider scope of
lenders to choose form and perhaps
potentially better terms
that's excellent so you just need to
speak to the letting agent and make sure
that that's okay absolutely there's a
lot of confusion I think about hmm
mortgages people think just because
you're renting out to more than one
person suddenly you need a big special
kind of mortgage no you definitely need
one if it's a licensed HMO yeah but if
it isn't then there's often some
flexibility in the approach with the
lenders excellent alright next what is
the minimum a mortgage company will lend
for a buy to let mortgage so if it's
just a an individual buying a cheap
house which is not going to be used as
an HMO what's the minimum no it's to do
with the minimum purchase price and the
minimum purchase price generally as far
as we know is 40,000 there isn't any
less than 40,000 40,000 pounds you're
gonna struggle to get a mortgage on it
definitely if it's 40,000 pounds or
above yes as long as the house is built
well and it takes the usual boxes
there's a 40,000 pound house you should
be able to get a mortgage on that yes
and that particular there's one lender
who will do it at 40,000 and they have
no minimum income requirement so if
someone has got no income yes 10,000
pounds and then individual they can go
ahead and buy a house I have to have
some income they have to serve some but
how much there is no requirement there's
no minimum income record you've got to
have something so if you if we put down
on the application well they don't have
any income at all sure then the lenders
likely to refuse him but if it was safe
just follow 10,000 perhaps at least
something yes that's right really well
that's good news
next what is the minimum a mortgage
company will end for a buy to let as a
company so if you're buying a property
yes as a limited company what's the
minimum there no range for the purchase
price of the property a lot of lenders
find that limited company buy-to-let
mortgages are more labor intensive than
normal and more expensive to run so a
lot of them say the minimum purchase
price of the property has to be 100
thousand yeah there are a few three or
four who will do it at less than that
the minimum we know of is that there is
one company will do a limited company at
a purchase price of 60,000 only wow I
thought it was 75 thousand there are it
was until a little while ago but there
is one company now
we know of who will consider a limited
company purchase possibly - just depends
on whether you fit the criteria right
great excellent what about if it's a
Monti lat
being bought as a company probably
seventy five thousand in most cases most
we usually advise people to go for a
hundred thousand hundred thousand is
better because almost all limited
company mortgage lenders with its atmo
or standard one will do a hundred
thousand pound but it's less than a
hundred thousand band there might be one
or two that will do it that's it there
are one or two we you know what we do
Wrigley is one or two so yeah that's
true what about if it's a multi lacked
and it's being bought through as an
individual what's the minimum purchase
price and again it could be forty
thousand that one at forty thousand if
it's a multi let with all people signed
in the same tenancy agreement sure it
does depend if it's not then probably
seventy five thousand in the industry is
the general rule of thumb really helpful
yeah okay next question I'm really
enjoying this Angelique Lycee for coming
on next question is can you buy a
company that owes a property yes and
take on the mortgage the answer is you
can the mortgage lender has to approve
you as a borrower yeah so I've done this
successfully about other times it's not
worked no and it's a question of the the
mortgage lender approving the person
who's buying the computer all the people
and then of course in an ideal world if
you're buying it from somebody that
person you're buying it from will want
to come off the mortgage because they
want to remove their liability for that
because they're no longer got the
company so so yes it is possible to do
that yeah okay bit more bit more topic
on and one of the questions that
probably normally asked is what are
interest rates currently doing at the
moment they're they're sort of fairly
level even the Darryl governor the Bank
of England isn't quite sure where
they're going himself is he generally
speaking of course we have to ask the
chap upstairs or woman upstairs from
whatever your point of view is on that
but my own opinion is that there they
might rise there what they always rise
don't they ultimately yeah they might
rise but I'm not confident that there
will be some large rises
in the immediate future why because
things in the economy are still not
particularly active we are struggling
with brexit and there's still a lot of
supposition that bricks it's going to
cause problems yeah so I and the fact
that the bank the governor of the Bank
of England keeps talking about rising
interest rates and then when it comes to
these and put them up suggests to me
that he keeps reviewing the situation
and personally I think it's a good idea
to fix the rate if you're going into an
enterprise because because you've got
the security of that but I'm not
convinced there's no evidence to me that
interest rates I mean you can get a buy
to let mortgage now about about two
percent two and a half percent yes which
is incredible I mean the fact that you
can fix interest rates obviously not
that low but for 5-10 years even a time
just kind of comforts me because why
would a lender let you fix that your
interest rates for ten years and knowing
that interest rates are going to
absolutely rock it yes so I mean they
are gonna rise I think but it's not
something behind
Elementor something that by the way you
said about five year fixed yeah there's
a there's an issue that is not generally
known in mortgage criteria if the
relationship between the rental income
and the mortgage payment is too tight
for normal lending sometimes a lender
will offer a five year deal and relax
the term slightly so we have found
occasions recently where the
relationship between the rent and and
and the interest payment is too close
for normal lending criteria but the
lender says well if you have a five year
fixed rate then we're relaxed our rules
slightly because we have the confidence
that you can be okay for those five
years and that's little known that what
are some case studies of some recent
people that you've helped right okay let
me think you've picked on one we had a
woman who I did it this morning and she
doesn't own any property at the moment
she's a tenant yeah she has not much
income and but she did own a property
two years ago she was on the deeds of a
property and we done her buy to let
mortgage yes so there's issues like that
that there are ways also of getting
people in on HMOs who don't have a lot
of experience
yeah and it's little-known you won't
find it on the software that we all use
but again I think somebody is coming to
your meeting tonight it's just done one
we've done it through them successfully
where she's bought one buy to let
mortgage or a property just on us an
ordinary buy to that and as soon as
she's had one month's income that she
can demonstrate on her bank statement
and she can produce the shorthold
tenancy and Linda has said what she can
now have an HMO because she has one
months experience it's not a general
issue thing you can't always do them but
we've been out to do it two or three
times this year so there are little ways
we can we can work round things if we
use our imagination I love it all of
them at you and row is you're very
creative and rather than finding
problems you find solutions we'd like to
think outside the box yeah yeah so what
would you suggest if someone wanted to
talk to you what's the best way for them
to get in touch how do you operate and
the easiest things to ring us yeah
probably the office number at the moment
is the best one the reliable one because
people ring on the mobile sometimes and
I'm busy or and I can take the call and
then I have to come back to them later
but if they ring the office number
somebody can put book in for us to have
a chat I'll put that below on the week
and thank you thanks thank you so much
for watching if you benefited from that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time